life on the road it's a taco tank or
strippers waving guns and these flights
canceled flights running with the runs
turn black this bounced checks great a
bachelorette bumps in the front making
out for your side and it likes doing
bowmore missing merge turn drive the
rental car has another megachurch turn
juice keys vagina fisted cell phone is
gone one big law and order marathon
uh by a factory or the Roosevelt okay
yeah you guys uh yes good yeah did you
want to complain Roosevelt Roosevelt
Hotel mmhmm yeah okay Roosevelt Franklin
Elementary School no no remember
Roosevelt Franklin is good all from the
Charlie Brown Baker ah my character from
that I mean yeah he was the one black
guy kid right left season I don't think
that's appropriate I think it is is it
when those card rooms were drawn there's
no doubt that super good point that is a
very good point thanks for turning the
road stories everybody i'm your host
marie valeriano part of all thanks
comedy go check it out if you have a min
all things comedy uh recently got a lot
of good stuff going on there I have to
apologize uh not to you gentlemen I have
to apologize my listeners for the for
the late drop this week i was i got
super busy this week manna for the first
time a very long time is that a humble
brag the saying that you're working now
uh no I think it's straight out brag
okay luck it just said it was really
because of the holiday and you spin a
little time with your family you could
have gone that route instead you chose
to be a show-off well I do my people
know I have got nothing going on in my
life this is it this is what I lived for
really yes until last week and you know
this is a subject I don't like to kid
about kill yourself this is all you have
I insist you slit your own throat in the
bathtub what do you think my plans for
at 1201 uh-huh right yeah see I make
sure this drops ever supposed to be late
real crackers when I introduce up to it
I believe this is a I'm gonna go ahead
and make this about me this this lures a
part casteth on tradition I you listen
you've said that before this is only my
second time here traditions gotta start
somewhere I was here once with no I was
your Raptor with Gary up right well but
that was for your uh when you guys were
filling in for Bill Engvall involved in
bail now pinball you know what here's
your sign haha now you're sorry weren't
you and I here once before yeah we did
this we did this you were here yes
together uh two years ago and then I was
here once with Gary bright well but I
don't think that was part cast is
unrelated it was part cast on related
cuz you came on the radio show
and did the podcast afterwards I did it
back to i tolerated this for more than
one segment two units two hours well I
for one I'm looking forward to repeating
ourselves no kidding oh my god I got
four stories I remember uh I'm throw the
beer thank you for having wait listen I
really have this is mike siegel
obviously in jimmy pardo thank you guys
for coming on I appreciate you kind know
both of you are very sought after the
podcast guest so I appreciate you cuddle
Jimmy is his own show I've got a new
shows a week this guy screen shows you a
week ago park esta thought coming up I'm
guesting on everybody's and there's
nobody I haven't said yes to and just
did it take to a camera doesn't exist uh
and by the way that's not true cuz
somebody's gonna go I did ask him but he
said no I'm very well he's doing
back-to-back road stories today Oh doing
to ya Oh couldn't do anything worse well
I need somebody to hand me my razor
blade I'll do that part I appreciate
that sure um mike siegel thanks for
coming I appreciate it but it's always
good to be here always always a pleasure
thanks I have to have to say I know this
is I this podcast is about you guys mmm
rice this podcast what is not about
Marie valerio spike us about the guests
but I'm starting this one off uh with
the benefit I did the other night sure
as my said Marie we're gonna we're
tapped out so you know God pull some
weight on your own should Jimmy ran a
marathon let's talk an hour for that oh
let's just go let's just save your Don
Draper stories for effort for the end
right Don Draper osino a raper in the RV
the only guy in Indiana oh it's the only
thing I can reference yeah I don't know
his first name is it doesn't i don't
know no paper from that night beach i
might be I gonna close trailer so as a
good American as I am I get asked the
headline this benefit down in tustin
which is in the orange county area Marie
can I say something yeah the gentleman
is a friend on the air to you sure real
headliner never says to him they just
say they're doing issue just your story
Jesus Christ that's a true sir comes
over the lamb ature I'm doing out I'm
doing you a favor friend forever yeah
you could've turned off the air probably
yeah that's gonna be my joy at this out
you can alright so I was opening
ahh real MC doesn't say the wrong show
okay all right um tell me where's doing
this benefit raising money for homeless
veterans to get back into the homes and
raise money for you know soap whatever
they put them in the homes now they need
soap and all that Stevie I get a text on
Super Bowl night from the woman who's
drunk woman to charge is drunk blow me
charge drunk go Broncos hey just talked
to somebody they're bringing some of the
vets be as dirty as you want now I'm not
a dirty comic but I'm also despite what
Jimmy thinks a professional so I saved
that text and I get to this place down
in Orange County uh she's like hey help
yourself to the bar really excited to
have you they opened with a prayer oh
boy did the Lord Jesus Christ our Savior
you sure yeah you don't find that odd I
don't because I I believe in that world
support our veterans oh this is nothing
to pray Lord to save you this is nothing
to get all glory to God that the brace I
don't know what you're asking me I don't
no clue Oh No except this is speeches oh
no what'd he say this victory speech in
Iowa we said well first things first and
I'm gonna freeze it all glory to God in
n mullins head Cruz voice enhancing but
just pandering to that on his audience
God did to do this yeah by the way i'm
not i'm not anti god I'm just act like
Ted Cruz no a listen we were not a
religious podcast here no we're never
that's insane Marie of course you should
open up a comedy show with a prayer a
prayer and pratica and it was it was at
a golf club to it was at a boutique on a
console oh gotcha so this full G Jesus
had a low handicap it was good like I
had no troll with the water and in the
sand trap never had a reek cuz he was
hit footprints right with you it's not a
Catholic any Joy's our Lord Burleigh
here's might think about that uh oh and
by the way i think thats and I joke
should have got more I I think yeah I
think you should have left it out there
I think he jumped on it to quit either
very well on the road no happy with it
all right I think I think he jumped on
it you should have let it breathe
property uh so you know when I say
here's the thing no doubt that's got
Mariano so they're homeless veterans Oh
show them how the one percent live at
the Country Club yeah oh yeah why not
sure he pays let's bring some veteran
but prayer will be dirty and then you
can see a bunch of guys and Tommy Bahama
shirts and khaki pants get in there
lexus's and drive away who are really
running the world yeah right now about a
veteran's we're here for you we're gonna
do a benefit before we vote to take away
your right and you find your benefits
you want to eat want to hear the hole I
dug myself uh yeah tonight's question
cherry hang up before your whole place I
see the prayer prayer and then how many
comics before you one just one guy one
uh and so once I did the prayer I'm like
I need a drink so I went to the bar in
the back and kind of rethinking my set
turn that water into wine I yeah I hear
laughter which I wasn't expecting cuz
second prayer cuz they close with the
Big Finish cuz the woman who booked this
said hey the openers not funny oh no why
would she say that I don't know when
he's just a offered text it's a off the
alcohol and second of all I gave her a
bio she should know my hey well then
that's what I said I'm like hey if you
know the guys not funny then let me
bring a friend I can to talk a friend
into driving down for a free meal in 10
minutes thermocouple bones and that just
[ __ ] send everything into a tether so
I'm like nevermind don't worry about it
I'll just I'll just do it myself so I'm
in the back I'm listen I'm like here
laughter I'm like oh alright these guys
want to laugh so I poked my head in the
openers doing all Street jokes all
Street jokes and then closes he's a
black man i have to point is ok then
closes with Keenen Ivory Wayans is only
bit that you would know Keenen Ivory
Wayans for doing I love Kate even think
one of that it's okay it's so one where
he has to go to school and and he gets
beat up by the bully every day and his
dad says you got to fight that bully or
you got to fight me and I beat the [ __ ]
out of my father that joke Keenen Ivory
Wayans no well this is anyway so close
kina everywhere just kills just destroy
courses in Ivory Wayans yes class just
absolutely destroyed we all know it so I
get up there and I dig my hole but I
saved that text and I said hey so
whatever name was uh texted me after I
guess she was really excited about the
promo
cuz she's a little drunk and said hey I
could be as dirty as I want and then you
heard all the butts pucker oh no yeah
and so then i said but then you guys
open with a [ __ ] prayer and then that
just ha ha ha just like a hole i did cuz
then i said then I went into my
religious stuff which is not very Pro
religious and then I've mentioned
something about them being Republicans
that if you're gonna put the people in
the war it's good that you put them in
the homes to or something like that
brilliantly that silence yeah they like
little boost maybe a little well but i
have to say brought him around had a
great set how long did you have to do it
i did a half hour have 30 half that of
whatcha got a meeting a headliner
wouldn't do only 30 minutes house coming
by to me by CB flooded our suits plenty
actually half hour of Keenen Ivory
Wayans material right because the solid
stuff uh I'm gonna do Pat Francis always
makes this joke is a comic by the park
le it's very common Paul Kelly Park
Kelly you start knowing you he never
enjoyed you know comments to sit around
you [ __ ] about a [ __ ] gig yeah that's
what you do is always horrible because I
miss this podcast on ya before Kelly
never had time for that it's like bhopal
furnace out what the [ __ ] we supposed to
talk about yeah that's what comics to it
he bro he's gonna bitter check check
cash you get your money well then who
cares our way okay I guess we're done
talking yeah that's I did this in common
I did this gig the other nights get paid
yeah done that's it mean that's not
funny that's all Paul ever wanted to
talk about what else do we have to talk
about 0 can't talk about our feelings
your real life no no family well
speaking of so did you have to hair
looks great today they don't disagree
with the hold on right I'm not doing
done anything real kind I'm really yeah
rolled out of bed yeah I shaved my balls
yeah that way they look good that also
looks good yeah it's here for short
shorts your uh whenever I just wake up
to and my hair looks fantastic and then
it's always when I go to get a cut
because it's like first thing tomorrow
I'll do that before i do my day the
longer it goes why do you want to cuz
it's look fantastic I don't trust me in
three hours it won't arrive in hair but
it looks great well thank you you're
keeping a high and tight though well
listen this
I marry I do what they call a reset no
I've been going in for nothing but trims
that's right puss saves in the last
couple of years and it was getting a
little uneven like it was great haircuts
they looked great but it was all growing
in the wrong direction and so I just
went in and got her done really short so
everything could start growing recall it
a reset now do they so sure that's an
innovator I've come to the point my life
where I've decided to cut my own hair Oh
Marie well you've given up my wife my
wife I decide to have my wife cut my
hair can I say this Marie real barber
doesn't ever certainly do kutta see now
buying Clippers this week I'm very
excited about what well cuz I looked at
the woman who cuts my hair and she bet
she does me a nine across and then I'm
like I can do what I can my wife can do
that can I direct you in the direction
of Jimmy Pardo's 2002 comedy central
special a nine-minute by cutting their
own hide almost I almost quoted it but I
was gonna let you do it since you're in
the room I do I'm just remember this is
like a chimp with a flowbee can get this
part of your head uh yes right right and
it just like this is where the top is
where they make money through my issues
where they make their money this is
where they see the dollar signs I Jake
Johansen good friend of he does it right
hehe flow bees still flow be still flow
be still flow bees yeah you cut your
son's hair I assume my way oh my wife
cuts my son's hair and it's time to stop
mommy can you trust her what are yours
she's going scissors with the four year
old who's you know freaking out I've
Clippers in and I watched my the same
woman do it for the last 20 years no
I'll also buy a hat when I by this goes
away and then if it doesn't work out
then we'll go get a recent my mom cut
our hair as a kid and man I look back on
though and this is the 70s where we a
little longer maybe took a little more
skill back then no yeah it's terrible I
look back at my photos and it's just
it's embarrassing really people go um
like I look at your hair I go yet mom
saved five dollars that also basically
was that back hair it was a bowl and but
it was uneven cuz I this giant cowlick
here and I really put a bowl on your
head though no but I mean she tried her
best to make it look horrendous and
worked it weren't sending her picture
quaff gay st. see what he could have
been look I'll see what her photos could
have is I tell you what man I am I I had
the worst mullet of the 80s I had never
with the mullet raha man who was I was
full-on chachi Baio parted down the
middle feathered 70s do this is and
we're talking eighties man I know I kept
it going too long got a little long they
were still look in the adj yeah yeah
then I had the college it was head we
get up we have a clean this up there's a
fine picture of mr. Pardo at the Las
Vegas improv I loved I love to email the
SNL one that's that one else shirt
that's that classic baby which of course
I always just say if you if you say that
a comedy club and you pull it off and
mail it to me i'll send you twenty
dollars what have been 50 at one point
at 50 I'm there in January hi June I
think a 50 yeah katek it all right I
don't have to wrestle Carl though that
goes like oh no that's on the wall
that's in a green room yeah oh yeah why
not oh you wanted all taken at all rain
uh somebody did it from I think was the
Madison club somebody went in there with
the screwdriver and took it off the wall
that's great I gotta say I've never seen
your picture on the wall hmm there's
some of the hmm really they have you
been to the improv here in Los Angeles
where it's you know the improv three
feet by two feet the improv exercise
it's right over there members know it is
unreal Reza oh it is you're on Melrose
aren't in adding [ __ ] nice eyes too
yeah 3 by 2 all right might even be four
by six oh how much for that if i take it
off the wall in mail to you nothing i
want another wall it's big yes lookbooks
milligram important is it the the at the
improv in hollywood they have those ones
it's like big ones and you're so they
have like Adam Sandler you know Andy
Richter you know all these guys gave no
hellacious yeah these guys are Ralphie
May and there's that one girl that
nobody knows who she is right and then
we find out it's oh that's uh Angela
Johnson Jose evangel up on the wall and
she was huge on there and God bless her
you know she's very successful but not a
household night I'm not when you're up
there next to you know huge gigantic
stars she's not you know what I listen I
don't know anything about this woman may
either I'm that's why she sells out
theaters but the comedy club like to us
do you like the fact that comedians are
going well who's that yeah that tells
you that she didn't get her chops at the
improv
oh yeah but she's selling out f in
theaters and like I said God all power
to her but I I guess atomic great every
but every giant photo up there and then
while I know who they are and most of
the world knows who they are and then
her I know the backstory on Angela
Johnson okay what is it so is uh she was
a YouTube had five minutes I don't you
something like mad TV or something like
I'd five minutes on YouTube got like
because of YouTube oh we got five
million because it's doing the the nail
lady right doing that I think so I think
so I never actually a lady think that
she does I was like a 445 es mail lady
or something I don't know okay sorry
okay go ahead that's and then that she
five million in it did she sell some
theaters then she got mad tv and then
she was also excited her she was also
like a UH because i'm at TV maybe a san
diego charger cheerleader what oh really
maybe a full professional chair leave
yet oakland raiders i think if we
googled it I think she was a cheerleader
why did she screw it you beautiful oh
yeah by all accounts very funny I've
done Zener Jimmy Carter though not a bad
looking guy also I do the best I can you
should see my hair when I wake up I look
fantastic she was almost one of those
people who came out like a russell
peters all of a sudden came out of
nowhere and then who's filling the
stadium over there oh that's got Russell
Pete right he can someone I've never
heard of can fill a stadium him with
[ __ ] Joe Bonamassa don't know where I
came from but he is all over the point
exist ten years ago all of a sudden
there was a world video bonamassa in it
and I have no to [ __ ] away and I know
music and not just imagine dragon like
where they came out and had a great song
into selling arenas but Joe Bonamassa
has been around for 30 years but like
well yeah I love his first album oh this
isn't his first others like his 19th
that's right and he sold out these days
20 years into what he got a publicist
yeah whatever I have two songs by joe
bonamassa uh that you would never know
it's him because you know he's this
because i can't tell you one song by joe
bonamassa it's you wouldn't yeah he's a
great guitarist but he had a couple of
basically melodic rock sort of classic
rock sound eagle no I'm air guitar
that's good uh they're actually great
but they don't sound anything you would
never know well you don't even know what
you're gonna mess he's very good users
if I or a joe satriani kind of
a clapping kind of guy would imagine
were closer to Clapton not as was not a
new to learn like the hoardings Clapton
and not as busy with his hands as a fire
I agree with both of those statements on
guitar players Clapton is boring and
busy it is tony macalpine and
what's-his-face yngwie malmsteen I think
I email do this about Tara I've been
really into chicago late me and I'm
really sorry that Peter Cetera is being
a [ __ ] or whatever because nine percent
sure it's on him but so is it coming I
have not followed up on this is he said
flat out he's nothing he was another
think he has walked away wow he's got
more important things to deal with in
the confusion I believe I read a little
bit of a letter it's very uh it's very
sad I cannot go on record speaking about
it okay i want but i will say this i
emailed you the other day cuz i've been
very since they got into Rock Hall of
Fame I've been really into Chicago and
I've always known Chicago but right I've
been really really into Chicago and
Terry caps my same his name right yeah
how do you [ __ ] that up I didn't know it
was like author or we do the part of it
kath am I saying that right I do nine
minutes on my hair and then I'm gonna do
the Pardo improvisation uh yeah Greg
guitar player I think he was like a
little bit ahead of his time cuz down
and back in the 60s they're all very
blues-based and he was doing that kind
of cool not quite noodling but really
fast runs he like a Peter Green type of
that's the guy they always quote the
leawood Matt guy it's kind of similar to
that Terry would play lead guitar and
rhythm at the same time somehow he would
do chords and play it was an amazing
some guitars thinks he think he's
completely horrible really yeah friend
of ours Bonamassa and okay [ __ ] do not
get those guys in the same room um but I
I thought Terry was great he was really
passed away again him Donny Degas
replaced him or love I think he's a
phenomenal guitarist than Chris pineco i
think is another great guitar chris
pentacle very good earlier she just did
you just see cetera i did at the saban
in beverly hills name is the best he's
been since the 80s he was phenomenal
cetera at the saban phenomenally third
row of my wife and i and he was he was
great great what does he do with the Amy
Grant do it does he have a chick sing
along
taking a woman up there does backup
vocal and does all the you duets Paula
Cole no he's not Paula conference pretty
good guess he just stays Stickley with
other pc initial people no um got Peter
case up there got to Phil Collins Peter
Criss Lord ah boy turns out I could do
this message I'll get that nine minutes
on here uh he uh he does the Amy Grant
one he does the share one oh right I
forgot about the share one hour night he
did I think the Chaka Khan do it but
sometimes he'll do the other one that he
did with crystal bernard leader of all
people from wings yet a hit with her oh
really yeah wow man i had a big crush on
her oh yeah seriously gorgeous what
about Chaka Khan check mm-hmm she rocked
me all she wants to do all she wants to
do so he didn't touch on it all the Hall
of Fame you don't even my days just say
he did say cuz this was back when he and
just in fact he had just announced on
his website the letter to the band
saying is long overdue fellas looking
forward to getting our trophy if only
Terry could be there sure sure I read
that off um and so you know what why
don't we show up do I'll strap on the
base will do 25 or 6 to 4 and give the
fans what they want and I look at you
know here we go and so just like two
days later is that the sub on so he goes
well I'm sure you all heard the good
news and everybody of course applause
and it goes they got el chapo Oh some
woman right behind goes that's not the
good news no kidding dunce you think
maybe he was making a joke you dumb kuz
cheese sauce how do you live your life
and then she hired Murray for a benefit
be as dirty as you a lot Broncos will I
be headlining well um you ever open for
a band I you know what I opened my very
first gig was opening one of my first
gig was nobody offered my friend Gary
Sharra's by bring it around to this I
like it was good real good here I'm
proud of you I open up for uh proud of
you oh I wish I could remember the name
of his BAM it was Gary shara down at
some in Frankfurt Illinois ooh uh and I
did all three like I open for all three
sets like I went back out and cuz they
were just doing a barber just a night of
them playing band
doing sudden they take a break and then
you come on then I was so I open to the
beginning and I went back up and did
another set and did it you wouldn't
beginning middle and end I was so raw
that I didn't know not to do that they
never had a comic open for him so they
didn't know not to do that um I'm sure
went horribly I'm sure it was horrible
did they give you the instructions don't
don't touch the equipment you can all
run of it don't okay you know what
nothing really just got your friends ask
you right it was my friend yeah I'm sure
if there's a Booker there he'd be like
don't touch the quit yeah did they
remember to introduce you every time I
read every went back up every time it
said you know here's a UH you know I
think they lied and said here's you know
from you know you've seen him on HBO one
of those [ __ ] seen as SNL t-shirt
yeah you probably his mistake my
headshots uh yeah was a I'm sure it was
horrible sure yeah well most man sent
most means I i I've only opened for a
cover band the Boogie Nights the cover
band they're a pretty decent-sized man
resided in size Arab I you know what
they somebody owns the name I think and
they franchise the dog so these guys I
they stated the same crappy Motel this
was up in Monterey and Jimmy Dore and I
were working this club that I don't
think exists anymore but some guy had
won the lottery I've done that gig you
know that guy I opened for uh english
beat uh dave wakeling dave wakeling at
that place really yeah yeah so this
place just opened and there's one of
those places you go in and we were doing
the first comedy night I think Jimmy and
I so I was going first and Jimmy was
closing it and we were staying at this
little crappy motel and then this these
uh this band came and they came for the
weekend so we were we were gonna do the
comedy show first and it was a weird
restaurant memory had always like Asian
fusion he had a sushi bar in the corner
he had and it was just like he was all
over the place we literally won the
lottery and it ends like I love sushi
and I love comedy and I love music ruler
oh yeah i got i also bought a Hummer and
i had a joke about those like douchebag
to drive Hummers and they told me later
yeah the owner bought one of those oh
right sorry but he so the Boogie Nights
were playing and
and they had all their crap set up there
and then we're gonna start the show
after hours and so since I was working
the good friend Jimmy door where I was
gonna [ __ ] with him after my set I came
off off stage and while Jimmy was I had
put like the boogie night they come out
in full costume I put on a big afro wig
and like sunglasses and like the leisure
suit and i SAT behind the drum kit and
like while he was talking I act like I
was too many things cap he's helped her
toy like ho buddy would turn around and
notice it was me I just crack up and all
he did and I was like making little puck
during low his talk and all he does he
looks back at me he was what the [ __ ]
and pops the mic back into the stand and
walks off stage oh oh so I got no laughs
no he just pissed off and the crowds
going with but but cuz they were like
I'm sucking focus away and Jimmy walks
up an ideal hugga Jimmy this mean i pull
the i pull the wig off and he looks back
us ah and he goes back man this totally
backfire is totally backfired thank God
he started smoking pot after thank you
so angry there were two times in my life
that I actually I did [ __ ] like that
that was one and it both went nowhere
that was the second time the first time
I was working in vegas in with the Todd
glass hmm and the first night so I'm
meddling in Todd's headline and I'm on
stage and the very first day started in
like on a monday or tuesday and then i'm
noticing during my set is like people
aren't looking at me they're looking
behind me and just Todd is like got a
bag of chips and he's just walking
around backstage eating just looking
around just dude that's it it just like
complete people like what the [ __ ]
this guy and he's just like looking
things and just eating chips and well
and I just like laughs I just are
laughing just and people don't know what
the hell's happened so I vowed that I'm
gonna get back at them like by the end
of the week so by Saturday night I had
met in the users in the excalibur hotel
and walking around Excalibur there's
people in like
uh you know old title garba yeah like
knights of the round table Renaissance
type yeah so I I meet the guy who's
wearing the jester outfit oh and I say
hey can I borrow that like one night
he's like yeah whatever so there so I do
the is the first show Saturday night I
get offstage and I run over to their
dressing room and he gives me the full
jester outfit you know the Harlequin
things like the curly pointed things
with the bells hanging off to her that
and the host oh yeah the whole thing and
I put that on and put sunglasses on and
I grab a martini glass vodka and I sit
during Todd set like about 10 10 rows
deep and I just start heckling him I go
not funny and I'm wearing this giant the
gesture and then he's like what the and
he looks down and he sees me and he goes
uh-huh that's you and he keeps going I
was like god damn chivda Geneva with
that I didn't win there and then I now I
gotta get back up and walk out in this
jester outfit like an [ __ ] yeah so
now I don't play jokes anymore I'm the
guy who if I get the joke played on me I
play it back at the person and then they
take it offensive yeah it's all me I
don't it's not that I go too far it's
just that they don't have the same line
that they put another you know what I
mean I do it's always all of a sudden
I'm the [ __ ] that's why I don't ever
I don't ever do that it man you know I
think it depends on the gig you know one
time was in Minot North Dakota and I'll
never remember the guys name but it's
already said this on the show if I did I
apologize it's been a year uh he I was
bombing miserably he was that he was he
was that Latimer and are you point out
other headlines yeah he certainly
appoint the other 1i unibrow by yourself
I'll respect I don't know every respect
for yourself they expect you to be a
headliner I'm on the show I'm performing
here we assume that your headline you
have to tell us o noble so well you're
wrong um I'm bombing miserably and he
came up and sat in the front row uh with
some popcorn and he would he would watch
me and I would get a laugh I would get
to a joke and you go haha
no he would he would laugh they look
around with rusty audience during at me
acknowledge like oh we're not going to
enjoy this any and it was the it made me
laugh and then so it's like you know
what I'm gonna do so that was like on
Friday night we had saturday night I go
you know what he didn't do a saturday
cuz I was actually doing well so I'm
gonna do it to him on saturday cuz dummy
doesn't get that he was doing cuz i'm a
bombing this is just one of something
years ago so he's going up and he's
doing well so i go and do the exact same
thing to him same just like you Mike
nothing that he gets goes uh yeah good
for you mother [ __ ] yeah the other great
one was speaking of Todd glass was down
at the old irvine improv and it was me
gary valentine and Todd glass and we
would rotate you know who would do what
spot and and so whoever was going last
of course the audience doesn't know who
that is so like the very first night
Gary Valentine's closing the show and in
the middle of my set he just comes up
behind me and turns the vacuum on it
starts vacuuming the stage and it starts
video and I'll go sir not night sir I'm
doing a show here this is not the time
wrong time for this we're doing a show
Gary sir I get you and I apologize so
then he does you know he's and then Todd
would do something to me and I would do
something to Todd it was it was like I
think the last week of the improv it at
the old location yeah and so it's like
nobody cared three of us just had fun
the audience was in on it they somehow
enjoyed it as well and it was great yeah
but the audience gets the impression
that you're oh you know each other then
you're having fun and they're part of
the joke and they yeah they get it but
man when they storm off angry it's not a
good Jimmy it's me do-do-do-do-do why I
guess here's the thing i would laugh my
ass off at that yeah i'm not so sure i
would today i would today right like as
you know the audience is there like look
this was not a great gig in one of
either I mean I was either making light
of ever just like he just yeah I didn't
want to be there anyway and we could
just tell at this club we were an
afterthought it was like he was trying
everything cuz he yeah yeah what he was
doing and that was also one of those
rooms where we've worked in enough clubs
where you go out there and you go this
place is gonna be closed within six
months where I went back a year later
place was the hottest room hottest club
in Monterey and like what did he do
different the music was no different
rid of the sushi bar hmm but and I look
at it and every bartender and waitress
all hot girls oh yeah and then we're
still doing comedy there yeah I was
there so it must have been but uh it was
less they couldn't wait it was so
obvious they couldn't wait for it to be
over because it's to MIT it was good
night everybody they pull the shades
away right you know just like music
starts and just you know I did I did
that I did a couple times at one time I
had it was during a boxing match and
they wanted to turn off the boxing on
the big screen you know this old it was
one of those like pull down right yeah
and they're like okay you know it's
going longer they thought it'd be so
we're just gonna turn off the match and
and you're gonna go on no oh don't know
that I'll stay as late as you want me to
don't do that it was all there's a bunch
of Marines or not Marines know it yet
there's something there right so
military or there's an intelligence base
or something where they go to school to
like learn translating and stuff like
that so yeah it's a big military yeah
who's the movie so just why the hot
girls sold the place well it starts at
the P a movie a movie platoon no good
guess so patty on getting there beside
an adventure oh just took a left turn
keep a military buddy oh oh that's a
ship side adventures ship yeah but it's
not a military ship you don't know who's
on that boat I do I seen both I thought
those are recently it was a captain you
have it down a military captain you
don't know he can marry you you don't
know what war she's fought well he be
ex-military mitten you gonna make a good
point Stars and Stripes it's in San
Francisco the Presidio yes there's more
than one there's more than one Presidio
mm-hmm what do you mean there's more
than one there's a Presidio down in
Monterey there's [ __ ] video and San
Francisco I'd like to point out I don't
know what Presidio means it's Spanish
for of the President yeah beside no no
no she jerks I'm motor all right but we
just did a benefit for the wounded
warriors as well wait at the golf
tournament when we played golf for the
woman well we yeah we that's okay that's
okay money and then that's a good chair
you you have to do like all this
background now about every charity you
do because we got some thing in the mail
somebody sends oh by the way wounded
warrior just got all this heat for like
using most of the money
for it doesn't go to the veteran space
I'll really wonder where really oh so I
said you know was kinda legitly but you
know we don't how do you know anymore
you don't know that's true plus you
can't trust the internet no that's true
we're the whole thing going about on
about a Salvation Army oh oh yeah that
was the owner of salvation army makes 5
million a year and blah blah blah and
everybody bought into it and you have to
be [ __ ] the Red Cross too there's
always but there's like I mean my wife
was surprised that I got paid to do a
benefit well that's always there it's
always the question isn't it when you're
doing a benefit I some could argue
you're the time you're donating is your
donation turn your time you're doing is
your donation and others would say well
fiance does it they're paying her to be
there because then they pay her and then
she attracts all these other people that
are in their gonna end up raising more
money but I'm kind of way I don't know
where I stand on that I kind of feel
like I want to make money then yet I
feel like an [ __ ] taking the check I
don't know what to do ever cuz a guy
came up after after the show and said
thank you for donating your time and I
was like oh I didn't know sir generally
don't like this I asked for a wounded
warrior to carry my golf bag not a wrong
we followed a guiding his time uh right
the guy in front of us had was missing
his late yes absolutely and you know him
to carry your bags I thought it was
inappropriate to laugh I don't know my
first ball tipped well they're my guests
on my show and I don't like to point the
finger I said Mike we have personally of
golf cart there's no reason to have a
man carrier bag Mike said I'm gonna make
this guy are in it I'm here support I'm
gonna make this guy go 18 holes right
Mike let him hit a couple of holes no it
was nice of a couple par threes he used
his leg I think it's very fair right I
remember I was asked to do this
tournament last year no ya know you were
asked to do a different oh okay Conan
that's right okay yeah that's it and
then came around this year he had
another fallout no we did not have a
father now really just went ahead and
ask JP ahead of me yeah how did that
happen how did I carriage a peak anatomy
oh I could do you want me to send you an
email list Wow on responses oh alright I
don't you have five hundred dollars you
wanted to spend Marie is how much it
costs to play you
really were you playing Pebble Beach
we're playing the upper donating to a
cause yeah our wounded warriors all
right real oh yeah all right I did offer
I will tell you this i did offer to host
the awards ceremony yeah the raffle the
raffle and all that because I did feel
like brother I'm here is a quote unquote
celebrity playing this Golf is like we
do it every year at Conan Bryant and do
a fine job thank you and I do and I
enjoy doing that I did its funnel do the
raffle but they had this guy a
professional auction guy doing in that I
thought was great at the same time
wasn't getting results like it was the
same four people bidding on every yeah
thank God for those four guys oh boy
would have been uncomfortable when
things just don't sell what are they
bidding for their what are you about
what I bet I wouldn't I bet I Mike I've
been on to turn my back yard into a UH
money green love putting green oh my
free landscaping free landscaping I bid
on that I went up to a magnet and which
I went up to but I regret not going the
extra hundred dollars to win it there's
a lot of questions in that though were
they only gonna it was it was it just
general landscaping like for the whole
yard or you have to have a putting green
can you just I went to the website
parently could do you know you know much
water it's gonna take to keep that green
though no no no I don't worry sir
artificial all artificial zinta gallons
Oro yeah it's all artificial so you
would rip up everything the backyard to
make an artificial backyard ivy putting
in Reiner min also it which is why I get
on mad I didn't go the extra hundred
dollars to win it huh cuz i went to
seventy-five thousand dollars and the
guy that beat me went to 75,000 100
right Joe right down to the ATM I
certainly could have but I was busy you
enjoyment the day of the golf course i
will say JP one a complimentary bottle
of Tito's vodka and some guys stole it
haha table I'm get stole it off our
table haha unbelievable um we used to do
this thing and we're thinking about
doing it but I don't want to organize
that we should do the comics open and
like 40 comics would where would you
play marie de bell golf course in or
just played there the other bank under
the what's that place that time well
look Carly out water or something like
that the Overlook Oh with that we go
there every year for father's day I love
it there we used to play there yeah we
put there a lot is great it's great it
used to be the because nobody would play
it so you could basically just call up
and go hey can I come at ten o'clock
yeah come now come on
your wants and that's what we did some
guy called up and said hey we have 35
comedians want to come down on friday
and they're like all right just started
laying out tee times and Chris Hardwick
one every year Chris Hardwick did yeah
he's amazing golfer and an amazing uh
bowler dad was a professional I don't
know they can't all chess player I knew
that I don't know about the golf yeah
Jesus give us something Hardwick haha oh
god the guy's handsome he's got 49 TV
shows now the [ __ ] guy putts better
than me I introduce it into podcasting
you gotta be kidding me hmm that can't
be true it's true no more he was a guest
on my show long before he was of course
no I'm gonna have to rethink that
there's some kind of a technology thing
he knew about it well before yeah Murray
I think that's crazy i should keep us on
before he was on my Mary I I'm gonna say
something no I don't know that okay but
secondly I don't want to keep knowing
but there's a agri with Mike Chris
Hardwick is the king of I maybe not
introduced him maybe that's a strong
word no no I'm reintroduce them I'm
guessing he had his own by the time they
may I you didn't have his own welcome in
his mine I sure did 2008 hmm try to
think of it no he was definitely on
there before he was worried you 2006
yeah Hardwick that introduced me to
Twitter actually I ran into him in the
indianapolis airport and I was coming
back from I was at the Kentucky Derby
hmm and I but I you can't get a flight
into Louisville because of the Derby
it's just like impossible so I flew into
indy and drove down so I came back that
sunday and he had worked the club in
Indianapolis he was just starting to get
back on the road and I ran into him in
the terminal and I said how was the
weekend and he said he's great sold out
all these was like money sold out that's
pretty good although shows it's like I
know you had a big following their he's
a yeah a lot of its through Twitter I
was like what's twitter and he pulls out
his phone it starts fouling up it's like
yeah i got these followers and they come
out to the show so i was like wow oh my
mistake it wasn't Chris Hardwick it was
Graham Elwood oh no no no grandma did is
to show at my house in 2006 oh sure no
no yeah he was one of the guys to give
in my home he's on my first episode
mom knows that my house no I hate I
really feel like I'm know handing you a
lot here but uh when you when you throw
out such ludicrous facts there's nothing
I could do yeah he think so he was at my
a was at my home he was definitely on
within the first year oh I'm thinking
parlor to my wife sleep who Paul
Gilmartin I knew yes but still no are
you sure uh-huh you never came to my old
place over on Hudson uh Paul would have
been on su mike mike siegel as Scott
Aukerman Paul Tompkins mike siegel Pat
Francis Mike Schmidt no my ball Mike was
on Oliver alright so wait what you're
remembering the order of you of you
starting Dodgers remember who came to my
home okay Aukerman glass Thompson
Thompson Paula Tompkins the pad francis
mike siegel hago Martin Graham Elwood
those are the guys that did at my home
oh that's between 2006 2000 gaza i
figured i'm thinking Greg Proops oh
there's a good chance of that that's
good chance that was a key tonight
voyance it was keen ahead i also had the
black guy the open for you down at that
benefit had that guy on 2007 oh you know
what else he did which was great after
every punch all right there was a podium
and he was smart enough to take the
microphone out of the podium it was
wireless mic but every time he did a
punch line he'd turn around and drink
his rum and coke or look his notes oh
yeah but it was like it was like punch
Lantern drink look at the note turned
back around and go knock knock was this
guy like a san diego uh Orange County
guy nice guy nice guy I did a morning
show once morning private gig ones where
I was not smart enough it was kind of a
combo I wasn't I didn't it didn't occur
to me to take the mic out of the mic
stand of the of the podium okay I admit
that it did not sure yet at the same
time I loved being behind it because it
was a barrier between me and that
audience and was like I wasn't funny
enough yet to have confidence it was
like having that they're kind of gave me
like you know little stairs yeah little
uh uh just security security blanket
really so uh but in hindsight it was
like yeah dummy you take the mic out of
the standing you walk around the stage
so that they enjoy you you're not a
lecturer
I asked Molly the worst benefit I had to
do was at the funny firm the old funny
firm in Chicago and they were doing some
benefit for the anti-defamation league
so is a room full of lawyers whose job
it is to single out offensive speech and
Baja people for it I'm so beforehand it
was I remember it was me Ali Leroi and
Franklin a job that's who I introduced a
podcast Franco panocha no are you sure
no I want to first what's at your house
before the show started and i went first
the before the show started there was a
lecturer some professor from
northwestern or something going up there
and basically boiling humor down what is
funny oiling it down to its most
scientific unfunny aspect mm-hmm all
right mark shake now comedy and it was
awful awful I was uh I know normal
executive producers don't say this but
I'll show running a pilot and I did not
get along with actually think you can't
say I can't say thank you I did not get
along with the woman above me at all and
it was turned out to be a horrible
horrible experience and what really put
the nail in the coffin was during tape
day she's like we're going over the
script because I was an English major
and I said nobody kills jokes more than
English majors well good for you which
is true because she was going in taking
out commas and all that stuff and that
just put the nail in the coffin for me
but I got to meet Mike Henry hired Mike
Henry Mike Henry the greatest is one of
the best one of the best writers in the
biz I agree was that as far as i'm
concern at work comedy life was i was
out here visiting once and somebody said
one of my first trips out to LA I just
started comedy probably doing it a few
years but I was my first trip to LA and
I had a cousin like not really i don't
know what this would be like my dad and
her mother were cousins you know she's
from New York I never bet thinking the
second color what maisie not even I'm
just a person you've met yeah yeah I
didn't know her didn't know her but they
said when you go out of my way yes you
should have lunch with you your cousin
she's in the TV business and I was i all
right so i won't say the network order
but she worked
uh she was in she was a current producer
hmm so basically she was the the suit
she worked for a sitcom it was pretty
well known sitcom but basically is a
current producer you're the network suit
that comes down to the set and tells
everybody what they can't say basically
right and so I shoes for she S&P lost
aunt was she standards and practices she
was she was the cool she was the network
person on sanusi executive in charge she
wasn't running the show she wasn't she
wasn't a creative side okay okay but I
had lunch with her and she said oh
you're in comedy I said yeah this is it
since you worked in the ship is a vp in
the comedy department and she told me I
don't really I don't go to comedy shows
that much I don't really like I just
never laugh and and obsidia crossover
going you're in a comedy executive at a
network and the years later she rose
really high in comedy development really
network yeah Tina Fey I don't think
she's in it anymore but uh what do you
say that Mike when she said I didn't
know what to say is I find myself going
well I could say like a green with it
like this cuz you're so I could see that
I mean you're around all the time yeah
so should I like it for Christ's sake
you deal with it all day ready Mick
comedy comedies and she was a smart
person but that's when you realize oh
she could be in any business she could
be working in an IT business but she
just chose this line of work and now
she's giving notes to people and I went
oh my god yes no it all makes sense oh
you know I so much crap gets on TV I got
it I got into this business backwards I
had a sketch show that me and my
partner's got a pilot deal out of and
got a huge agency and when that fell
apart nothing else on my resumes out of
me but we were pitching and we had it
sizzled before sizzle this was like 96
so who's even before sizzles and we had
a sizzle reel and we were showing it
weird at MTV and we showed it and
they're like yeah so you can see how
kind of we're influenced by Monty Python
and the young ones like the young ones
like yeah this is British like British
TV shows like oh I don't really watch TV
you're in it the executive MTV executive
at MTV my favorite I i said and i say
this one on ever show because and so
people are going to go here's this story
again
was I had a meeting at E I don't
remember the woman's name but it was at
E uh it's got me a decade ago and I knew
that she didn't want to meet me I knew
that she didn't want to meet me and so I
went into it in middle they went in with
a bad attitude but she was also being
very unpleasant because she did not want
to meet with me sure and I believe her
quote was dad the world seen enough of
jimmy pardo we get it like that and then
something's like but you should see him
for this he's perfect for this job okay
I'll see him by the way Thursday book
that I should know that Roy yeah yeah
hey you're gonna go into this interview
know this she doesn't really want to see
you like why the [ __ ] would you tell me
that so I go in and I could tell she's
just tolerating it and then she says um
she goes well tell me so who are your
influences who are your idols I said
well obviously the top Idol is Carson
sir and she goes oh my God he's grown so
much as MTV hasn't he ah and I went well
Johnny Carson hey oh yeah that's before
my time I went okay we're done and I was
like I go you know let's wrap it up and
then you know I left school boy boy you
seem to have it i glisten i don't know i
am here i don't know why you want it you
know why you agree to see me when it's
obvious you don't have any interest in
hiring me for this and there's a God
then she called my agents like boy you
came in with a bad attitude so I wonder
why what do I came with a bad attitude
you dumb coos here's my here's my role
and we don't have this is not meeting
talk but here's my rule for meetings if
you're 20 minutes late I cancel you walk
out I walk out I just say hey listen I'm
sorry uh you're obvi he's obviously very
busy i have another meeting let's
reschedule can i call you later to
reschedule anything after 20 minutes
they're pushed back so far you're gonna
be having a meeting while they're having
lunch or you have a meeting while there
take another call I've just done it to
make that 20 minutes I'm not gonna be
like 20 minutes [ __ ] it kick over a
drive right but I'm like hey listen I
have another appointment at three he's
obviously very busy let's just go ahead
and reschedule and then they call you
know what it's usually like you know
what this probably better he's really
backed up to it's usually not a half
times out of ten no wait is it's a guy
in this scenario you don't think women
could run this country you want to call
somebody a cooze again I know right x2
in one show I don't disagree with that
Murray don't think I didn't hate myself
a second time i used it don't think I
didn't hate myself but did something you
so Mike made me think of you know I was
in the record business back in
the early eighties there were the tiger
internet was that r you ain are now
sales rep own mca records but you know
we were all were in the same office but
there was the people that couple sales
guys didn't give a [ __ ] about music at
all like it was you they might as well
been selling vacuums they just wanted to
meet their quota they needed a sign of
sales they wanted to get their sales I
wanted to make their yeah you know get
their bonuses and all that then there
were some that were there because they
loved music and I just assume because
for me working in record stores and
getting that job to work for a label
like here we go i got the dream job it's
give me a bunch of like-minded peel i
get the record store it's a record store
about working for the label and it was
like oh no they don't some people here
don't give a [ __ ] about this at all
right when you realize it about sales
yes not passionate about music and
they're usually like like I left before
the record industry crumbled but some of
those guys they literally didn't it's
like oh that's over I'll go over here to
Procter & Gamble and sell this now this
is what I do is like I would have been
devastating what the [ __ ] am I gonna do
now this is my life I don't have that
sales gene at all oh I didn't either I
was horrible at home I take no for an
answer it's bad I couldn't even sell
Eminem's for Little League Oh Michael
yeah I uh this out you don't want these
do you I gotta sell them for my you know
you might gain weight you know haha
diabetes you don't need that I remember
I had a foot when I first moved to town
I got the phone job that for surveys yes
to do movie surveys which and your
training the surveys like for question
generally go this is a piece of cake
then on your first day it's 37 pages and
everybody hangs up on you and they're
like you have 90 days to meet your quota
and I was like all right I have 90 days
to find a new job because I decided I
this out on a 90th day man so I put a
fire under my ass to get a real job well
you see how at any these are big
corporate studios and networks and
agencies they're all big corporations so
what how they start you realize in the
hierarchy how they weed out the free
thinkers and the creative people is
through the assistant process usually
got to start out as somebody's assistant
well most people like a lot of
screenwriters and people like that and
producers they all went off they were
starting a somebody's assistant when
[ __ ] dis I can't take this so I'll go
write my own [ __ ] right and so the
freethinkers and the independent ones
leave so who's the ones that left are
the ones that sit there and take the
[ __ ] they're good they don't make waves
mmm they don't you know give you put
your neck out you know it'll get chopped
off and you'll something fails that's
another gene I don't have assistant gene
yeah organizing stuff look at this by
clean this before you came thank you
it's still disorganized you don't have
to tap that you to picture Pat Frances
gave me two years ago ice 11 hung it up
on the wall that looks good there it was
like a baby you did that for me it was
nice of him before we talk about Park
casteth on yeah I I getting back to
benefits did a benefit a couple years
ago and I apologize to my listeners they
probably heard this but I've been told
it in a while so you'll enjoy it again
uh it was me and a comedian named Mike
pace Michael patient very very great
comic originally from the st. Louis area
mike is that possible I think so all
right now you know he lives down in
Southern California yeah that was not
there yeah and look funny he was funny
that night I know that's the only time I
ever worked with him and it was for a
company called surgical benefits which
I'm like surgical benefits just start
writing my own jokes you know oh boy a
scapula again you know whatever you know
all these jokes then it turns out that
they do facial reconstruction surgery
for either inner-city kids or poor chill
or sadly people have been beaten you
know kids who have suffered abuse and
and all that's only obviously scrapped
all those jokes I wrote on the 405 those
first thing as a headliner you know how
to do that ah so the you know just yeah
um and so again it was one of those
professional MCS you know he ran the
auction and then he introduced everybody
the buffet and he called for table for
your you know go up and he's like okay
we're running a little behind but I was
opening the show and microscopes in it
we're running a little behind so you're
gonna go on in like a half hour I'm like
fine grab something to eat half a heart
turns into an hour that Mike pace and I
are in the back just bitching Gus [ __ ]
come on what are they doing they're like
okay we're coming up to the comedy but
Marie before you go on we have a special
guest speaker from benefits from
surgical benefits I'm like all right
sweet a doctor these guys are a snooze
they're gonna want to laugh after this
it was a sixteen-year-old girl who had
the facial reconstruction surgery Paul
came on and
did her speech and closed with through
tears if it wasn't for you guys I
wouldn't have a prom date this year yes
crushed everybody just bawling tiering
and meanwhile in the back going I kind
of followed her I can't follow this is
ridiculous i can't follows and then the
god then the MC goes well Lisa or
crystal on so whatever your name is uh
as a surprise for you we brought the man
who performed your surgery dr.
Rosenstein dr. Rosen Oh hadn't be Jewish
memory I wish quest crystal lounge I'll
get hurt in this story by the way I
wonder I meant to say Angela Johnson I
don't know whoa I don't know why I wrote
that so me and Mike bitching for the
last hour the guy in the room goes
excuse me Oh who is dr. Rosen Stein
comes out and they just bring the house
down in tears and you know it was over
yeah yeah yeahs done and like emits
crying you've seen him on Comedy Central
Marie Valtor 'into just just in just 20
minutes of death just silence people
were getting up and going to get tissues
you don't have to go get drinks the only
thing the only thing I remember is uh
Christopher Knight was in the audience
Chris 900 radiator break Peter Brady
grapey Freddi and I kept looking at him
and my instincts are like go to Peter
Brady guess it's the only way that's and
you guy could just sitting there don't
don't belong to me don't drag me into
your hell hack previous and so that's
why I was really nervous about the the
last country Christ I was in a country
club down in San Diego where it was just
they were [ __ ] mine I just remember
the one country club Orange County story
that I had that I had to go down there
and did a benefit for the some traveling
softball team down there which they're
from it was like Laguna Beach or
something it was something really
beautiful and it was on this bluff
overlooking the sea and just and I found
out these there were like highschool
girls but they're traveling softball
team and that they travel all over the
country and this is their fundraiser to
pay for you know everything and and I go
down there and they again they do all
the stuff beforehand they have the day
her and then they start dancing like
they have a DJ there's like everybody's
up and dancing well what's the dancing
starts this this nights over oh yeah
yeah yeah I said and I kept telling no
we have to go on before the DJ kicks in
you know you don't go DJ then comedy you
know most people are up out of their
chairs over it's like we'll talk during
dinner I don't care but let's get up
there now we just we set it up this way
you guys will go on after and it was me
and rusty nails yes t nails no yeah
that's a good know I was going give her
birth given boy that's given yeah and
somehow I plowed through and again it
was like that ok now everybody sit down
we're gonna start the companies like no
they're up there already danced like
they're already drunk there at the bar
they're doing they're just never do
comedy after something funner than
comedy right brought you up and I as
some i plow through with them half the
people ignoring me couldn't hear less
stuff everything I was like I'm done I
get out I get my check i'm leaving the
building and as i'm leaving i hear rusty
from stage going shut and i was like
done take a run to my car started who's
i'm gone it was like oh I couldn't wait
to get it's like by the time he's off I
hope to be yet i'm on the 4 or 5 i'm
done gone haha as I'm walking out the
building like thank God I'm gone I got
hired to do a kids and do a graduation
once from KJ riddles the guy kill ya
came to our riddles KJ riddles in orland
park illinois and the guy came on a
sunday and saw me it had a great set and
then the party was the next weekend he's
like I forget what he offer me it wasn't
a lot of money i did this is evident to
be it was but it wasn't you know and he
also owned the local maybe I told us
last time I again I don't remember what
I don't get doesn't that doesn't ring a
bell he owned the local Nautilus
remember nardil this was a big new
health and health club is not all those
health club and I said to him said you
know what I've ever Sheila I've been I'm
on the road I'm lazy and I said but so
instead of paying me why don't you just
give me a year membership because all I
can't do that buddy I'll pay you your
money so because you know membership was
probably i don't know fifteen hundred
dollars or what everyone here okay but
in reality it's not
thing it's error yeah you're not giving
me anything you dunce so you got I can't
do that buddy i'll pay your rate you
know so he paid me and I show up and I
am just effing bombing note it was a
family it's a family graduation uh the
kids are graduating 8th grade I thought
they were graduate know about oh yeah I
kept on saying what college you going to
uh no III don't know what Callie I don't
know yes I don't know what college i'm
going to and and so i kept an aunt and
they all look like that's the graduating
teen idiot their children their children
but they looked older than that and it's
like well why would you hire a
professional comedian who you saw the
club entertain children right and so I'm
bombing and then the grandmother larly
at one point walks the grandmother walks
from the restroom back to her chair
stops in front of me goes back with the
quit the wave of the hand like from
right to let drag and then somebody says
why don't we get I'll make up a name
when we get Ricky up there Ricky let's
get Ricky up there I go I go I'm sure
Ricky's great folks but you let me down
I just want to do my time and get out of
there calling out for Ricky your call
for Ricky Ricky is six but does
hilarious let's be dozen fairness does a
great George Bush impression you know
but he's doing faci to entertain a car V
right not gonna happen you know he's
doing but he's six so it's [ __ ] great
yeah so he kills and then hands the mic
back to me and I go oh so I gotta follow
the kid no just go off just horrible but
it's like di got buried by a six year
old saying three lines from dana carvey
zach horrible hmm and then the guy was
like it goes I he goes well i guess i
guess i have to pay you right i go i
said i did my time man you get my money
he's like well I go I said hey I tried
to give me up I give me a health club
membership trust me I was never gonna
show up for that stand for this like I
couldn't show my face to that guy oh man
and it was like it had to be nothing 200
hours at the more like it was nothing I
was green in the business sir so it was
like dummy just over valuing his own gym
membership like think you're giving me
nothing well when the people i don't
know when the woman told me about the
guy she was hiring i apologize if this
guy's listen to my podcast i don't mean
to [ __ ] on the opener from this
think I'm not but he was you know she
saw me at the brea improv it was the
best that I had like 50 of my friends
were there there were 75 people and we
go well no wonder you had such a great
set of your best friends were there who
obviously never heard a knock knock joke
like that but I will say this is 11 we
came up after I me after the show and
she remind me of mrs. Carlson from wkrp
in cincinnati she came up and she like
hit me in the arm and she goes why do
you hold back oh and I oh I've hold down
like you're looking at the only
political material i have you know i'm
not jimmy dore at all she's like those
white rich white Republicans need their
dick knocked in the dirt oh wow and I oh
yeah she goes I know because I'm a rich
white Republican huh like sweet do you
bad i'm married mrs. carl mrs. Carlson
we all need love and Mike they do only
lovin strudel times I tell us about park
asset on before we wrap it up Mary
podcast about a diverse almighty come in
our ears some very busy Hollywood
players right here I got a gig you got a
meeting you I have a thing yeah wash
your hair oh not do don't do not like
that every time I tried it I don't know
when the last time you had headshots
today's the day three o'clock right
after I kill myself oh boy you get your
busy day for you forgot you had that at
noon park has Devon is on marks fifth
you could stream it live at never not
funny calm repeating never not funny
comet is the 12 mar 12 hour marathon
version of my podcast never not funny to
raise money for Smile Train the
organization that goes to third world
countries and does the surgery to fix a
cleft palates cleft lips of children and
adults that kind otherwise afford it
each surgery only cause two hundred
fifty dollars and only takes 45 minutes
I had the opportunity to go down to
Mexico this past year and watch pet
francis and matt bell lamp and i hosted
and they invited the three of us down to
watch a procedure and so we got to meet
some of the families we got to meet the
the doctor has been amazing it was
amazing it was you know to get a twitter
but it's a it's life changing it's it's
it to see the joy and the love and these
parents faces when they see their
child's face being you know changed I
mean it really was it was amazing to see
just the you know the one dad who I
teared up when he would show me the
before and after he he just pointed the
doctor and you know we think speak
Spanish I don't write and so he just get
looked at it and he was just kept on
saying all him all him mmm and it was
like oh god here and that was on the
first for 10 minutes i'm already sobbing
right right and then to meet the kids
and the murray went up and did 20 the
murmured were brought up after that 30 i
was that again the the funny part the
funniest funny thing that happened there
is is they took us coming down there is
an opportunity with the city of i was
Chapas or tapas like this yesterday's
estate its weight or whatever the city
wasn't it but it was the city we were
meeting the president of choppas and
they're signing some big crazy thing
that the city is about to support Smile
Train even more than they have been so
some big like just these people signing
and news coverage and all that Nate so
they use us coming down from America so
the president comes into the room and he
goes I use the three fancy doctors from
Los Angeles and I go no no no we're
comedians comedians at doctors and like
thinking I'm being funny right so he
gives this wonderful speech in Spanish
and and and one point egos and the three
and a woman's translating the three you
know he says basically the three doctors
and I go go ha mother effer so and I
turned to the woman I'm supposed to
speak after that and I said I said I go
you probably you probably I don't want
to talk now but Jack has comic I go I
don't want to make the president of bad
she goes no I'll clarify it and so I
said well first things first there were
actually three comedians that host a
benefit for Smile Train and the
president which is class goes oh so you
support the you cure the mind of the
hearts and the doctor cures the fit like
he look at that spun it wonderfully and
I let us off the hope it was like for
like I described as power mr. fine who's
three jackasses and we have these three
and apple we know three fate we have
these three guys from other three
doctors of Los Angeles Oh me a patent
matter like Oh for odds but you could
write you could donate money right on
never not funny calm there's a donate
button on their different guests on
every I guess half hour uh in
past incarnate o'brien and jon hamm mr.
Silverman and patton oswalt and as your
brother knew uh nope JP is only for the
golf course and only the very last
second only when we ruled out everybody
else do we go to JP but it's still it's
sold out though and it sold out live but
but you listen it never not funny calm
it starts at noon pacific three eastern
and uh just about raising money for
Smile Train judo till midnight what are
you doing this year we go noon to
midnight and noon to midnight noon to
midnight yeah it usually bleeds over a
little bit but pacific time pacific time
new civic is noon to midnight and then
three p to 3a on the east coast okay I'm
tuna sushi I'm gonna be on the road so
no but I'll try it we get again your
street member I'm gonna stall stream it
on my phone on the drive back so
probably driving back on the fit
solutely Palm Springs love it you're out
of fantasy springs casino yes the improv
there mm-hmm I like that good good to me
i'll tell you this marie what's up uh it
took us one time when i went out there
Danielle and oliver was very young it
took us five hours to get there really
and on Friday just on a Friday oh yeah
never go into Friday and it took the
other two comics six hours to get there
so we had to start the show late and we
all basically just went up in the
clothes we were in our car yeah because
and gotten the guy by the way and had no
sense of humor about it with added
editor oh he was really he had he was
mad that we didn't leave at 9am like it
was I'm and we all were like we left it
no dude took five hours to get here it
took you seven really takes two and a
half right we I gave it double the time
and he was like he goes well you
should've been more perfect like he was
mad at us slough I remember Pat Francis
talked me into going to see haulin oats
with him last year at fantasy springs
casino I didn't know Pat Francis drives
like a grandmother oh is that true oh
yeah dude six hours what some way that's
how I remember it six hours one way I'm
like I'm driving it can't be you you
gotta go to your way to make us six
hours it seemed like six hours that's
how I remember it was a long time what
are you so shocked it took you five and
a half well it based on his story you
guys Hardwick the podcast well you're
right are you sure took us five hours
took the other people 6247 took us six
great are you nuts with six or less it's
unreal you're right what the [ __ ] the
matter with me I'm turned on me I'm an
idiot thanks for coming oh there's the
drill hey as tradition we do every year
from now till March fifth any my CDs or
t-shirts that you guys buy will be
donated a podcast if I thank you for
that dude do it every year it's part of
the tradition I know but I say thank you
for that anyway to be a generous
recipient of such a good Mike you sit
there and look pretty okay so yeah so my
obviously my my uh CD through my website
you can buy it on itunes but the money
won't come in till later justice how
they pay so or you can just go straight
donations at Murray valerio com or and I
put it in from the road stories
listeners I don't put it in for myself
so you guys get credit also and you guys
do it every year and I appreciate that
and as do I thank you and yet so guys I
want to thank you Mike you're on all the
time thanks for thank you for always a
pleasure for coming on here and I can't
believe we didn't get to talk to you
about your three crucial crucial errands
ya next time well guys never done one
cruise ship in his life he sent three
and four weeks loves the sea spa babe
yeah maybe that day my friend haha my
body's at home but my heart's in the
wind Oh shiver me timbers I met my
family met Brandi I should find girl oh
you guys know yeah okay yeah make a good
wife something but i had to tell her the
love of my life my lady it's the sea the
sea well don't pay the ferryman at least
you get the other side oh is that what
you do it mm-hmm I'll tell you didn't
pay the fare don't do it before no no
you paid me to get the other side he'll
rip you off what day is pissed yeah oh
yeah all right good to know you guys
thanks for listening will talk to you
soon thank you
life on the road it chews tacos egregore
strippers waving guns and these flights
canceled flights running with the run
jump like this bounced checks crazy
bachelorette don'ts in the front making
out for your set and mid likes doing
ball more missing merchant drive the
rental car has another megachurch turn
juice keys vagina 50 cell phone is gone
one big law and order marathon
Oh